Bon dia. Tot recollit ja. Diumenge 8 d'agost.
Tot bé, la gent se'n va anar d'hora a casa, vaig poder dormir, però tota la nit gossos bordant.
Fins a les, no sé, fins a les 6 de la matinada, gossos bordant.
Ni amb els taps, tu, podia deixar d'escoltar-los.
Mira que no he vist cap gos, eh? Ahir no vaig veure cap gos en aquest país.
I resulta que tots els gossos del país estan en aquest veïnat.
En fi, és una mica tard, llavors són les 9 menys 10, clar, perquè necessitava dormir més i...
Doncs surto més tard, tu. Vinga, let's go.
Per cert, sí que se'm va caure una cosa a l'aigua, eh? El tap de la crema solar.
No és drama, però no veig la manera com recuperar-lo, eh?
Recordem que ahir em van recollir dos quilòmetres més cap allà,
per tant, si he de continuar el camí just on ho havia deixat,
he de tornar dos quilòmetres enrere.
I llavors, engegar el tracte i tornar a començar.
No volia fer autostop per només dos quilòmetres,
però, bueno, que tothom s'ha afegit a portar-me, només han sigut, res, menys d'un quilòmetre.
És que no sé, no diria que no han sigut ni 60 segons el que m'ha conduït.
I la de seguida li he dit para.
Bueno, ja he engegat el tracte.
Solana, C. Carral, Pols, carretera, cotxes.
Som-hi.
A les 11 i pico he arribat a Gossard, crec que es diu el poble aquest.
Veig antenes de 4G allà, la cobertura és atrosment lenta, és brutalment lenta, és exasperant.
No sé si podré pujar el vídeo d'avui, vull dir que sí, sincerament.
Bueno, en qualsevol cas, m'han dit que hi ha un cafè per aquí, no sé com serà el concepte de cafè en aquest país, crec que...
crec que serà bastant diferent.
Fot calor, és complicat.
És complicat.
País complicat.
Bueno, he trobat l'únic bar-restaurant de la ciutat.
Puc carregar la bateria.
No tenen wifi, evidentment.
Mira, estic molt ben enfadat perquè Megafon, la companyia aquesta, en teoria, doncs, és la que té millor cobertura en zones rurals.
Per un pari de persones que he preguntat, funciona millor T-Cell, aquí, bastant millor.
Enganyi i falla, enganyi i falla.
Me'n faria un altre cim, eh?
Me'n faria un altre, tindria dos cims i ja està, però avui és diumenge.
Està tancat T-Cell, per tant, res.
Doncs no sé si podré pujar el vídeo, no ho sé.
Bueno, de mentre m'estic menjant això, que he preguntat què és això, i em diu KFC.
Ah, jo, bueno, vale.
Doncs KFC i una Coca-Cola de RC Cola.
Xar, Barcelona.
Barcelona, Barcelona, estan dient tots.
Vinga, va, molt dur, eh, avui.
He continuat a ventre, al pitjor lloc de la volta amb una peu, i crec que m'hauré d'anar acostumant, perquè en aquest país serà així.
Era enfurat a terra, com tants altres llocs, no?, que he fet, però era molt estret, era un rectangle molt estret i s'havia de fer punteria,
i alguna gent no havia aconseguit fer punteria, i hi havia algunes restes per allà, i no he fet foto, era realment fastigós.
Però, bueno, tenia una pica al costat, llavors, sempre és una mica més higiènic per no fer-ho a la muntanya, vull dir.
Bueno, a tu.
No m'envegeu tant, eh.
Hi ha gent que m'enveja molt, no m'envegeu tant.
No m'envegeu tant.
Porto un munt d'estona veient venedors de síndries al costat de la carretera,
i aquests nois me n'ofereixen un tros, no?,
no m'entén l'anglès, però crec que m'han ofert.
A veure, què tal les famoses síndries de Tadjikistan?
Can I cut a little?
Puotser referien a que la comprés...
It's good?
A veure, té pinyon, bueno.
Mmm! Molt bo! Very good! Pragmat!
M'he trobat aquí una paradeta d'aquest senyor que ven això, que és una espècie de sopa freda.
No sé què és, eh? Vinga, fot-li, fot-li!
I mola molt perquè té aquestes tateres amb una bomba i van com... no sé què... picant, crec.
Quan m'ha costat això? 3 soms que són 30 cèntims.
És igual que la sopa que vaig menjar abans d'ahir a Uzbekistan. Molt bona!
Hello, how are you? Name?
Tajikistan.
Tajikistan. Enric, your name?
Name.
Bye bye.
Bueno, d'haver canviat de bike o algo, la cobertura, sense ser espectacular, funciona.
Tinc el vídeo tres quarts pujats. No m'ho he adonat.
Ha sigut ara quan he obert el mòbil i dic, ostres, pujarà, pujarà.
Això sí, porto més de dues hores i això, ha pujat 3 gigues només, eh? Amb dues hores i pico. Tela.
El de demà segur, és a dir, el d'avui.
Aquest segur que no l'arribaré a pujar perquè faré un desviament.
Aquesta vall és més oberta, com es veu, i passa una mica més de vent.
I fent calor, seguim fent calor, però passa una mica més de vent i és més agradable de caminar.
Bueno, m'han enxampat aquí al costat de la carretera i m'han dit, vine, vine, que en durarem de menjar.
I m'he trobat que això no és un aniversari, aquest era el compañero, felicitats, i aquí hi ha un munt de gent.
El cap de Tajikistan.
Rahmat.
Hi ha un munt de gent i, bueno, no sé molt bé què en donaran, però ara aquí sóc a...
Em sento com un marquès, tampoc sé si m'agrada, eh?
I a dintre la sala aquella també hi ha moltíssima gent, bueno.
Rahmat, eh?
Rahmat.
Thank you to you.
Bueno, per acabar un xai.
El servei se'n va estant fluixet aquí a Tajikistan, també està bé.
Tothom molt simpàtic.
Ara m'he fet foto amb tothom.
De fet, estaven tots sentats al meu costat mirant-me els nens i els heu dit, deixeu-lo
de menjar tranquil, i s'han anat.
Bueno, quedaré aquí tota la tarda, però he d'anar tirant.
Em sap greu anar-me'n, també, perquè m'han donat aquí un festín, eh?
Està a punt de tronar, pel que sento.
Bueno, Rahmat.
Bye bye.
Ciao.
See you.
Good luck.
Rahmat.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
Much love.
Rahmat.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
Mare meva la de gent que hi ha aquí.
50 persones o 70 com a mínim.
No, no, més, més, més.
Bueno.
Ciao.
Espera, engego el track.
Thank you very much.
Rahmat.
Very good.
Piyoda.
Dushanbe.
Adeu.
You are the best.
Ui, ui, ui, els trons que se senten de fons.
Thank you very much, eh?
Adeu.
Adeu, gràcies.
A veure, la situació és la següent.
Són uns 1.200 km en total fins la frontera amb la Xina, dels quals ja n'he fet 100, per tant
queden 1.100.
Si ho divideixo entre 35 km al dia, que és conservador, perquè a vegades faig més, algun
cop n'he fet menys, però normalment faig més, però bueno.
Són uns 31 dies i pico.
Si li sumes 3 dies de descans, són 34, posa-li 35 dies.
Si avui és dia 9 d'agost, vol dir que pel 14 estaria creuant la frontera amb la Xina, no?
És justet?
Bueno, jo crec que a mitjans de setembre encara es pot anar perquè hi ha zona, pel que tinc
entès.
Llavors, Xina, quant de temps seria?
És un tren petit del qual la major part no puc fer caminant, perquè tant a la frontera
de Tadjikistan com a la de Pakistan hi ha part que he de fer amb un transport, val?
Amb un cotxe i amb un bus.
Llavors, bueno, Xina, doncs podria estar dos dies, però bueno, allarguem, va, posa-li
una setmana, no?
Per dir alguna cosa, perquè potser em ve de gust estar a Xina, és que és un tram molt
petit, que ni tan sols és la Xina que coneixem tots, eh?
Però bueno, llavors posa-li que, bueno, fins al dia 20 o 21 de setembre creuaria la frontera
amb Pakistan.
També és justet, però bueno, crec que és possible.
Per tant, anem en teoria bé de temps.
Per tant, bueno, decidiré fer un detour.
Faré una petita desviació.
En comptes de seguir per la carretera fins a Dushanbe, creuaré una mica per les muntanyes
d'aquí.
Si la meteorologia respecta, que ara clou un pèl, res, quatre gotes i sento trons de
fons.
Hauré de mirar la meteo.
I si respecta, doncs ara, d'aquí dos quilòmetres o així, ja em desvio cap a les muntanyes
i demà començo un trek, una missió secundària.
A hores d'aquí, doncs, ja em desviaré cap a les muntanyes.
A un pas, bueno, ja us explicaré més, però és un pas bastant elevat, un pas amb molta
altitud.
I després veurem dos jacs que en teoria són molt macos.
Sembla que aguanta amb poca pluja.
Bé, aquí tinc el desviament ja, després de dos dies i pico per aquesta carretera.
Què diu aquí?
Artuk Beyskamp.
No sé molt bé què és l'Artuk.
Una muntanya, no?
Kulikalon Lake.
Probablement aquest nen, no ho sé.
No sé el nom dels jacs.
I Rodaki Mausolem.
D'acord, doncs ara sí, sí, toca el desviament.
Per fi deixem acabant d'aquesta carretera nens rodejant-me per variar que no em pitjori el temps.
¡Vamos!
Sí, sí, sí.
¡Muchas gracias!
¡Hasta pronto!
Hello.
Buen día.
Buenas noches.
Hola, buenos días.
¿Cómo te llamas?
¿De qué tipo?
De mi.
¡Pyoda!
¿Pyoda?
Eee...
Art...
Artxurg?
No, Artuch, Artuch.
¡Gracias!
Es un no parar, es un no parar de gent que s'ofereix a portar-me.
Fins i tot gent que va en sentit contrari, que dius, què no veus que no anem a la mateixa
direcció?
Normalment sempre són homes, però abans una dona amb un Mercedes s'ha ofert també a portar-ne.
Bueno, tu, ara ja es veu com més verd, ja estem als 1.100 i pico metres de desnivell positiu, eh?
I ara serà ja tot pujada durant dos o tres dies.
Música
Bueno, sis i mitja, no hi ha moltes fonts, no hi ha cap font.
Aquí hi ha aquesta aigua que ve de dalt,
a dalt hi ha un canal, crec.
Confio en aquesta aigua, n'he agafat una mica i està bastant tèrbola.
Jo no crec que sigui de contaminació,
sinó és terbolesa que aquesta aigua deu ser com amb molta terra, molt argilosa, el que sigui,
i tot el Tadjikistan l'havies baixat així.
Llavors, bueno, n'he agafat una mica per mi mateix, pel meu cos, per dutxar-me,
i ara una mica la filtrarem al filtre.
Espero que no em trenqui el filtre perquè, clar, si al filtre li poses molts sediments al final s'acaba col·lapsant.
Música
Però és que no hi ha un altre, tu.
Aquesta muntanya tan guapa d'aquí es diu Sharishak o alguna cosa així.
Té 4.600 metres, que és molt, i el pas que he de fer jo està més cap allà, no es veu.
Patia per si estava nevat, però veig que si el Sharishak que té 4.000 no està nevat
o té uns flaquets de neu molt petits, doncs el meu pas suposo que estarà bé.
Música
Molt bèstia aquest paisatge, eh? Lluny al costat del riu, tot verd, prats, arbres.
Però la que puja és uns metres ja, tot és un sacerral brutal.
Jo imagino, no ho sé, que potser la primavera, en comptes d'estar tot marró, està verd i deu ser preciosíssim.
No ho sé. Però, bueno, si també mola, eh? I les muntanyes aquestes de fons.
És que no em canso, no em canso de gravar aquest paisatge. A més, a aquesta hora del dia.
Música
Molt bé, a les set allà hi ha una espècie de poble. Aquí hi ha una espècie també de petit poble.
I aquí hi ha el riu i hi ha una espècie de, com veieu, una espècie de comporta, no és una presa.
La veritat és que les obres hidràuliques no eren lo meu a la uni, no sé per què serveix això.
Però aquí enmig hi ha una espècie d'illa, que no és una illa. Sí, sí que és una illa.
I crec que podria ser un bon lloc per acampar perquè no crec que hi hagi ningú.
Perquè cap allà dalt... no ho sé.
Bueno, 36 km crec que va sent hora.
Música
Uau, aquest lloc està genial, eh?
Mireu, havia sigut en algun moment un parc, perquè tenen això aquí posat.
Està bastant devesat, és a dir, és una mica devesa perquè jo crec que aquí hi duen a venir vaques.
I es mengen al sotabosc i per tant l'herba està baixa.
L'únic problema és que hi ha una mica de remor forta del riu. Però bueno, no passa res.
Uau, aquest lloc està perfecte, eh? Mireu, mireu.
Mireu la gespa, que plana, que està allà.
I a sobre pomes, tu, si tinc gana. Això són pomers.
Mira, mira, mira quantes.
No tinc gens de gana, eh? He dinat un...
Vale, aquest prat, aquest pratet... Mira, és que a més no em veuen des de cap casa, eh?
Aquí, bé, no ho sé, des d'allà dalt. Però bueno.
Ok, planto, em dutxo i fem resum.
Uf, necessitava aquesta dutxa, eh?
Em sento molt més fresc. Tenia tot el cos ple de pols, sal i suor. Molt millor.
I a més, s'ha barret tan neta, tot net.
36 quilòmetres i pico avui.
Desnivell, no ho sé, ho veureu en pantalla.
He parlat amb, jo què sé, jo què sé, 6 persones, 7.
Converses de més d'una ola, eh? Si comptem els oles, potser 50, tranquil·lament.
7-8, bueno. De diners, res. M'he gastat l'esmorzar aquell.
I ja està, perquè la resta m'han convidat i tal.
Posa-li 5 euros.
I de refrescs, 2 només, diria. Sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, m'ha donat una mica el suc, de suc, a la festa aquesta. Posa-li 3.
Un te i cap cafè.
Bueno, ha sigut un dia durillo al matí, bastant durillo, i per la tarda molt millor.
Però en aquesta vall, home, això ja m'agrada, això ja m'agrada.
La temperatura ara és perfecta.
Hi ha unes cases allà, jo crec que no em veuen i si em veuen és igual.
Aquí n'hi ha unes altres, però aquestes, pel que he vist, sembla un lloc d'esdeveniments.
O sigui, crec que no estan habitades, sembla un lloc que fan esdeveniments, casaments o el que sigui.
Veig alguna llum, però no veig ningú. Bueno, igualment, tampoc em dirien res.
I la carretera està allà, però hi ha un mur. Hi ha un mur de bloc.
De formigó, llavors, doncs no em veuen des de la carretera. És perfecte.
Molt bé, doncs demà ja comença lo maco, maco, maco de veritat.
Bueno, si això era maco, doncs demà encara més.
Tinc moltes ganes, crec que podré pujar el vídeo perquè veig una antena.
Només tinc dues ratlles, una mica timo, una mica timo això, però bueno.
Bueno, us ho dic ara i no us ho dic més, vale?
Moltes formigues, eh? Espero que no m'embaixin la tenda.
Us ho diré ara i no us ho diré més.
Si algun dia no puc pujar el vídeo, el que faré serà esperar a que tingui cobertura per pujar-lo.
Ja sigui el dia següent, dos dies més tard, etc.
I llavors, tots els vídeos n'hi ha enredarits.
Per no pujar dos dies dos vídeos. En un dia pujar dos vídeos, perquè això no mola, no?
Els aniré ficant a la cua, no? Fins anar fent així.
És la meva idea, vale? És a dir, si el dilluns gravo un vídeo, però el dimarts no el puc pujar,
el dimarts no el puc pujar i el dimecres tampoc,
el dimecres tindreu el vídeo del dilluns i el dijous el vídeo del dimarts.
Bueno, tot, és igual. Però jo sempre us ho diré, vale? Quin dia és avui i tal, tot bé.
Molt bé, senyors i senyores. Bona nit.